翻訳: Yuta Kawamura
校正: Hiroko Kawano
マジックは何千年もの間
人々を魅了してきました
古代エジプトの参考文献によると
その始まりは紀元前5000年にまで遡ります
また 貿易を行う魔術師の壁画が
スペイン北部やフランス南部の
洞窟の中に描かれています
古代ローマやギリシャでマジックは発展し
次第に世界中で人気の
パフォーマンスになっていきました
このようにマジックの歴史というものは
長く そしてとても豊かなものです
皆さんこんにちは
マジシャンのRyu-ka(りゅーか)です
（拍手）
今日は皆さんに２つ質問があります
まず１つ目
皆さんはプロマジシャンのマジックを
生でご覧になったことはありますか？
あるという方は 手を挙げてください
少ないですね
では２つ目
マジックを実際にやったことはありますか？
こちらも手を挙げてみてください
さっきと同じぐらい ー
少ないですね
見てください
マイナーです
（笑）
一体何の質問をしているのかと
皆さん すこし不思議そうに
してらっしゃるので
いや 先にまずは僕のマジックを
皆さんにご覧いただきたいと思います
今日はひと組のトランプを使います
といっても 小さなトランプだと
皆さん見えないと思ったので
今日は こんな大きなトランプを用意しました
トランプにはマークが
ダイヤ、クラブ、スペード そしてハート
４種類あります
そして数字が 1から13
エースからキングまでです
では いいですか？
先ほどから頷いていただいていた —
その場で結構です
お好きなカードを何か１つ
仰っていただいてもいいでしょうか？
（観客）ダイヤのエース
ダイヤのエース
メジャーなカードです
（笑）
あっ ありました
ダイヤのエース
今なら カードを変えていただいても結構です
マイナーなカードに
変えなくても全然大丈夫ですよ
（観客）そのままで
そのままで ダイヤのエース
今日は 各マーク
ダイヤ、クラブ、スペード、ハート
それぞれ１枚ずつ使いたいと思います
では 今度はいいですか？
では ダイヤだったので
残りクラブ、スペード、ハート
何か１つ好きなカードを仰ってください
（観客）ハートの８で
ハートの８ いいですね
マイナーなカードです
（笑）
もちろんメジャーなカードに
変えてもいいですよ
エースとか エースとか
（笑）
全然 誘導ではないですよ
（観客）じゃあ ハートの
エースに変えてください
ハートのエースで
エースが続きますけど大丈夫ですか？
エースで
もちろん打ち合わせではないですね
（観客）はい （笑）
ありがとうございます
エースが出てきました
こんな風にだんだんエースが続くと
怪しくなってくるんですけれども
では今度は いいですか 端の男性の方
（観客）じゃあ クラブの５で
クラブの５ いいですね
分かってらっしゃいます
（笑）
クラブの５　クラブの５　クラブの５
クラブ５
ありました
今なら変えていただいても大丈夫ですけど
（観客）あー 大丈夫です
変えなくて
変えない
ありがとうございます
クラブの５
今ダイヤのエース、ハートのエース
そしてクラブの５ときました
ではラストは いいですか？
（観客）スペードの７
スペードの７
ラッキーセブン スペードの７
いいですか 変えなくて？
はい 今 皆様に無作為で
ダイヤのエース、ハートのエース
クラブの５ そしてスペードの７を
選んでいただきました
もちろん いろんなカードがある中で
完全にランダムで仰っていただきました
ごめんなさい
最初に説明を忘れてました
実はこれ 普通のトランプじゃないんです
ちょっと大っきい だけじゃなくて
ちょっと変わったトランプです
といっても 何か種や仕掛けがある
怪しいトランプではありません
「F」 大文字の「F」
大文字の「O」
小文字の「m」
「Z」「J」「g」「L」「N」
「f」「K」「d」「a」「R」
いろんな文字が書いてあります
実はトランプというのは
ジョーカーを抜いて52枚
そして アルファベットは26文字
大文字と小文字で
足すと合計52文字
このトランプの裏には１枚ずつ
アルファベットが書いてあります
例えば ダイヤのエースと
仰っていただきましたけれども
例えばこれ ダイヤの５だと
アルファベットの「F」が書いてありました
これ ３ですね
３だと「O」
各カードに１つずつ
アルファベットが書かれています
今日はこちら
皆さんに仰っていただいた
４枚のカードの裏を見てみましょう
まずダイヤのエース
バツ
「x」ですね 小文字の「x」
では ハートのエースと
仰っていただきました
これが「 E」
クラブの５
これが「D」
さあ もう嫌な予感がしますね
（笑）
これ スペードの７が
（観客）すげー
「T」
（拍手）
これで TEDxになっています
ありがとうございます
（拍手）
さあ 今皆さんに拍手をいただいたように
マジックというのは
素晴らしいエンターテイメントです
にもかかわらず 先ほどもあったように
日本ではメジャーではありません
今日はこうしたマイナーな
人、もの、ことが
メジャーになる メジャーにする方法を
皆さんにお話したいと思います
こちらの三角形 —
これはサッカーにおけるピラミッドです
と言っても抽象的ですね
このピラミッドの大きさは人口 —
そして 縦はそのレベルを表します
上に行くほどそのレベルは高くなります
実は世界で一番行われている
スポーツというのはサッカーで
2001年の統計データによると
その競技人口は２億４千万人にのぼります
もちろん 上の頂点には
W杯の選手やプロサッカー選手
そして中間には趣味や仕事で
サッカーに携わっている人
そして部活動でサッカーを
やったことのある人
ボールを蹴ったことのある人
２つ目
これはカーリングにおけるピラミッドです
日本では最近メダルを獲得したことで
マイナーな競技から少しずつ
メジャーな競技に変わりつつあります
そして３つ目
マジックのピラミッドです
（笑）
世界大会が あの上の方で
ま ちょっと小さいですよね
今日はこうした
小さなピラミッドを大きくする —
マイナーをメジャーにする方法をお話しします
では どうすれば
マイナーがメジャーに変わるのか？
大きく分けて マイナーを
メジャーにする方法は２つあります
まず１つ目
マイナーに属する人が
メジャーになることです
例えば とあるマイナーな
ピラミッドの中のある人が
突然 メディアに取り上げられたとします
そうすると そのとある人は
ピラミッドから抜け出したことになります
ピラミッドを抜け出して
周囲の方に認知された人
いわばスターが登場したことによって
今度はそのスターを目指す人たちが増える
そして この中間層の活躍により
だんだんとこの中の
ピラミッドの人が増えていきます
ですが 突然ピラミッドを抜け出す —
例えばメディアに
取り上げられるといったことは
こうしたTEDxに登壇する
みたいなチャンスがないと
なかなか巡り会えません
かなり現実的とは言い難いですよね
もう１つ
もっと簡単な方法をお話しましょう
同じように マイナーなピラミッドの中に
とある人がいて
今度はその人が
ピラミッドの外にいる人に
そのマイナーなもの、ことを
話したとします
そうすると当然
先ほどまでいた外の人は
その瞬間にピラミッドの裾に
入ったことになります
もちろんピラミッドの中の人口が
増えれば増えるほど
そこから 秀でたプレイヤーが
出る確率も高くなります
これはマジックにおいて話すと
すごく簡単で
マジックを見せた後に
種明かしをする —
それだけで裾に入ったことになります
ではこの２つの方法を使って
僕がどんなふうに
マジックのピラミッドを変えたか
少しお話しします
僕 今日プロマジシャンということで
出てきたんですけど
プロとアマ
実はマジック界には このプロとアマを分ける
明確な免許や資格などはありません
どれだけマジックのピラミッドの中で
上位に行くか競い合ったとしても
１つピラミッドの外にいる人から見れば
それはプロであるかという
認識にはなりません
「プロ」と聞くと
僕たちはサッカー選手や野球選手といった
プロスポーツを想像します
ですが そこにも同じように
プロとアマを分ける免許はありません
では 何をもってプロと言えるのか？
それを考えたとき
スポンサー企業がついているかどうかが
１つの観点になると僕は思いました
そこで僕は 日本初の
スポンサードプロマジシャンになりました
スポンサー企業がマジシャンについています
日本初 —
初ですよ
（笑）
「初」ということはもちろん
ピラミッドを飛び抜けています
最近ではありがたいことに
僕を目標とするマジシャンも増えてきました
それから最近
僕が教えていたマジシャンの後輩が
コンテストで２位をとりました
今ではその彼に憧れて
マジックを始める人たちもいます
ところで 今日のテーマにもある
『爆発』
皆さんは爆発がなぜ起こるか知ってますか？
爆弾があるから
火薬があるから
間違いではありません
ですが そこに火をつける何かがあるから
爆発は起こります
マイナーなものをメジャーに変えるというのは
自分一人だけの力ではできません
例えば僕と同じように
マジックをマイナーからメジャーにしたい
いろんなマイナーなスポーツを
メジャーなスポーツにしたい
マイナーなもの、ことを
メジャーなものにしたい
そう 自分と同じように考えている人は
周りにも たくさんいるはずです
そこにも そこにも
そこにも あなたの隣にも
あとはそこに火をつける
今日は最後に皆さんにもう一度
マジックを楽しんでいただきたいと思います
でも今度は見る側ではなくて
演じる側として
今日は皆さん 配布物の中に
輪ゴムが入ってませんでしたか？
今日はそちらを使って
皆さんにほんの少しの間
マジシャンになってもらおうと思います
ステッカーを留めている輪ゴムがあるはずです
ありますか？
ではその輪ゴムを
皆さん 準備しておいてください
まずは僕が一度 目の前で皆さんに
デモンストレーションをします
輪ゴムが見辛いと思ったので
少し太いゴムを用意しました
すごく簡単なマジックです
人差し指と中指にゴムを掛けます
まずは一度ご覧ください
手を握って開くと 一瞬で
ゴムが薬指と小指側に移動します
さあでは 皆さんお楽しみの
禁断の種明かしタイムです
（笑）
人差し指と中指にゴムを掛けます
そして内側に引っ張って
手を握り込む際に
４本の指 全てをゴムの中に入れます
あとは手を開くだけ
（観客）おー
今日はせっかくなので
皆さん「せーの」で同時にやりましょう
さあ では人差し指と中指に
ゴムを掛けてください
そして握り込みながら
秘密の操作をします
わかりづらい方のために
おさらいしておきましょう
人差し指と中指に掛けて
さあいきますよ
せーの
（観客）おー
できました？
（拍手）
自然と拍手が湧きおこりましたね
（笑）
今日は長々と話してきましたけれども
最後に皆さんに２つ質問があります
１つ
プロマジシャンのマジックを
生でご覧になったことはありますか？
ある方は手を挙げてみてください
今見ましたよね？
（笑）
全員
では２つ目
マジックを実際に
やったことはありますか？
こちらも —
あ 手が挙がるのが 速かったですね
皆さんさっきやりましたよね
全員
メジャーです
（笑）
「一体 何の質問なんだ？」と
皆さん不思議そうにしてらっしゃるので
最後にもう一つ種明かしをしましょう
これが マイナーをメジャーにする方法です
どうもありがとうございました
（拍手）